Speaker 1: Somewhere in America today, Tucker
Carlson is alone.
Hiding under his desk in the fetal position,
sucking his thumb, crying for relief, crying
out to his creator that things aren't good
because the census report just dropped.
There's been a stark decline in the population
of white people in America.
And that is that is something that is going
to send him, him and his white supremacist
cohort into a tizzy.
Reading from The New York Times, this article,
A Rise in Hispanic and Asian Population Fuels
US Growth.
Census reports the United States grew significantly
more diverse over the past decade as the populations
of people who identify as Hispanic and Asian
surged and the number of people who say they
were more than one race increased, the Census
Bureau reported Thursday.
Overall, population growth slowed dramatically
over the past decade.
The growth that did occur an increase of about
23 million people, was made up entirely of
people who identified themselves as Hispanic,
Asian, black and more than one race, according
to these data.
The first racial and ethnic breakdown from
the 2020 census, the white population.
Here we go.
Are you listening, Tucker Carlson, with your
great replacement theory and your your your
your dog whistles to white genocide, which
is a racist conspiracy theory that white genocide
is happening through low birth rates and the
promotion of higher birth rates with people
of color real reasonable.
The white population, the United States for
the first time on record declined over the
course of the decade.
People who identify themselves as white on
the census form have been decreasing as a
share of the country's population since the
1960s, when the United States opened up more
widely to immigrants outside of Europe.
That drop was driven in part by the aging
of the white population and a sharp drop in
the birthrate.
Again, this was expected.
I mean, some of these these dips or the increases
in in the rate of population of Asians, for
instance, was surprising.
But this has been long foretold in white supremacist
circles as something to be fearing that diversity
is our weakness.
Tucker Carlson famously said that immigrants
make our country poorer and dirtier.
And Laura Ingram has long whined.
About the changing demographics in our country
that nobody voted for, no white people are
asking for this.
This is good news.
Diversity is a strength, racial diversity,
diversity of thought that it is our strength
when people have different lived experiences
and they all work together drawing upon the
disparate lived experiences of each other,
good things happen evidenced by the our country,
the progress we've made over the course of
the last 50, 60, 70 years when things were
not good in America.